[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to a long
time ago director Paul Verhoeven
director Robocop it was also he also
directed Total Recall it was awesome he
also directed Basic Instinct of which
I've only seen this scene but I hear the
rest is awesome and he also direct his
Starship Troopers it underperformed at
the box office got mixed reviews at best
left an awkward and confused feeling for
many of the viewers who saw it and it
was awesome
[Music]
though getting a bit of a cult following
in recent days at least enough to
warrant shit shaped cookie cutter video
sequels many audiences still aren't sure
what to think of this film is it
secretly saying something provocative
just another hot people vs. monster
movie or both people can't decide if
there's an aggressive message to this
movie or not which ironically could be
part of the film's intent what do I mean
by that well let's take a closer look at
this film to find out let's squash some
bullets with some possible commentary on
fascism heavy you right now are going no
duh you're a happy you are going no duh
let's take a look at Starship Troopers
it starts off with a recruitment video
for the mobile infantry the futures
version of the army you'll notice like
in any commercial everyone in the ad is
beautiful and when we enter real life
everyone is also beautiful rookie movie
mistake or clever hint that this is all
satire of possible future propaganda
laugh all you want benign use but I'm
convinced there is more to this shit
buster than meets the eye
it's not that the film gives us
background on the enemy earth is
fighting the bugs as you'll notice it's
almost comical how little information
they give about them blend after source
of the bug meteor attacks to ensure the
safety of our solar system's plentiful
must be eliminated we never really get
any more information than that we don't
even know why the bugs are throwing
meteors at us as the focus is more on
just making the villains look evil and
the heroes look strong together maybe
not entirely together a news report
during an invasion on the bugs is
interrupted which is a shame when you
have such great journalistic lines like
this
their interior design leaves much to be
desired good to know that while the
futures PSA since her outfit Gore and
this live footage apparently is fine to
post in primetime news look kids that
might be daddy bleeding strawberry jam
and I for one welcome our new insect
overlords like to remind them that I can
be helpful and rounding up others to
toil in their underground sugar caves
cut to one year earlier as those future
cadets are in school learning about how
that one year earlier cliche is going to
be a staple of bad film openings in
about 20 years
Rico Rico pay attention answer the
question about why my arm is a baked
potato
this is Rico played by Casper Van Dien
who has the hots for Carmen played by
Denise Richards
he draws cartoons of them getting
together because as you can see this is
clearly the looking physique of your
everyday average cartoonist you may also
notice that the teachings in this future
are not quite as um peaceful as we're
used to this year we explored the
failure of democracy something given has
no value and forced my friends is
violence the supreme authority from
which all other authorities derived this
is why president Alec Baldwin is the
leader of our humble country Rico and
Carmen go to see how they did on their
finals I'm totally gonna be a rocket
scientist in a Bond movie now 35 percent
very nice Wow count-o loss latest
disguises his best yet he boasts Rico
scoring big letters to Amelia at him
again making you wonder what kind of
world allows that option in their public
computers as they hurry to their bug
dissection class led by dr. Nefario like
to think we are nature's finest
achievement grade it just isn't true the
are to be bred and slaughtered indeed
it's a tough future where lab coats and
gloves are for wimps and the weakest
student scoff up potato soup in protest
you'll find people being covered in soup
it's a constant theme in this movie oh
and psychics are apparently a thing in
this future too as Count Olaf uses is to
let the feed to see if he can bring out
psychic powers Enrico trust me when I
say you're not gonna find much in Casper
Van Dien head
I see Ace of Spades good guess but wrong
Count Olaf though demonstrates his
powers on his pet ferret go bug mom
Cyrano and find my hosting of the Oscars
amazing I sure hope you don't do
anything like that to me don't be afraid
can't do human yet he's officially
scarier than the bugs again I'm not sure
if that's intended we see that this
future clearly doesn't have the film
concussion as not only our football
uniforms even less safe than before but
they predict it stuns even goofy
cartoons wouldn't be able to manage the
game Rico gets ready to go to the Big
Dance
well he is 29
but as folks are upset at the idea of
him joining federal service to go fight
bugs after graduating said teacher isn't
it what's his name
mr. rad check him yes it is thank you
for doing my job for me movie and let's
be honest is it any stranger than the
actor's real name I think this character
would actually be more awesome if they
called him Michael Ironside I don't
think anyone in the audience would mind
at the dance we discovered that while
Rico has the hots for Carmen another
girl named dizzy has the hots for Rico
after tonight must have a father once
each other again
don't just be friends dis I mean it is
our last night together surely I can
start a relationship with you now I want
to talk to mr. Ike jack they better
hurry up the troika incest
[Music]
dizzi Andrew and now count Olaf's
impression of Neil Patrick Harris
pretending to be straight again scarier
than the bogs Rico finds out Carmen is
joining federal services too but
honestly I tell you'll be paying
attention to that after I point out this
guy how is he doing I mean there's jazz
hands and then there's dance
surrendering I think this is Dan
surrendering the next day they signed up
with easily the most chatty of office
clerks fresh meat for the grinder hey so
how'd you kids do I'm gonna be a pilot
good for you
we need all the pilots we can get next
time we meet I'll probably have to
salute you
infantry sir good for you mobile
infantry made me the man I am today
another line would go a lot faster if
you would just give them their papers so
where do you come from I was born in
Mississippi back in the good ole Europe
I hear my life story after saying
goodbye to one another we cut to more
propaganda which as you can see is
difficult to tell the difference between
VAD and this film's reality a murderer
was captured this morning and tried
today execution tonight at 6:00 all net
all channels Mary Hart will be hosting
and I'm executed
[Music]
if you think you're psychic
maybe you are hey wait that's bullshit
lassie doesn't believe in psychics those
believe in demonic wood peckers has gone
up rico arrives to his new home to
discover how aggressive it is your
senior career sergeants in second I got
I'm only here because our lee Ermey is
too busy filming the frighteners he does
get a little company though as dis is in
the same group as him as well as a
show-off named ace get in line like
everyone else you got some guts for a
rich kid and you've got quite a career
considering you're related to Gary Busey
these finds out though what happens when
you don't follow orders who needs a
knife in a new fight anyway Joe at wall
trooper now show you to be a crumpled
Jon Heder caricature so just ask the bun
to put his hand against the wall and
you'll be good
anything that's far-fetched check this
out coed showers Johnny what about you
I'm going into politics then you know
you've got to be a citizen for that so
here I am there's an irony that in a
future trying to show that men and women
are equal this was probably just done to
get some boobie shots granted there are
some side dicks but they're pretty much
on par with the Austin Powers naked
scenes so um fascist ish progressive
fish meanwhile Carmen seems to be doing
well with where she's stationed while
she flies around the set of space mutiny
Rico's group plays capture the flag
launching him into the spotlight
you shot church you can't killing
fucktard oh when they use live
ammunition fighting the toy story army
men
Rico tells a soldier to take off his
malfunctioning helmet
I'm pretty sure we can still say them as
punishment the soldier who shot him is
sent away every Co has to get a
talking-to by hanging from Breaking Bad
I think the soldier getting sent away
got the better deal Hank is tough why
did you order your man to remove his
helmet during a live-fire exercise I
need everyone in my squad operational
sir let's ride administrative punishment
administrative punishment by the way is
getting your shirtless ass dragged in
front of everybody and being goddamn
whipped again kind of feel like the
soldier that actually shot the guy got
out pretty easy compared to this but
down on this Sun Alps I know I've gone
through this too just not in public
you do have to wonder where the hell did
they acquire a guy to whip people for
the military no less so it says here you
have experience as a professional
witness
oh yeah years of experience and what
made you want to pursue this profession
oh you know no well sometimes you just
get tired of surprising friends and
neighbors consenting friends and
neighbors and it wouldn't be a surprise
now you've got a point and I just
decided that I want to give back to the
community by whipping people for a good
cause we see this more as a tragic
necessity than a good cause you're sure
but if you got to do it you might as
well do it with a slightly aroused smile
on your face you are by far the scariest
person I've ever met in my entire life
but thankfully that's a qualification
you've got the job now with all due
respect please attempts to never see me
again
why does everyone I ever meet
[Music]
[Applause]
so while Carmen is out piloting the ship
and asteroid from the bug seems to be
floating towards the captain we're in
the path of an unidentified object
moving toward us at high speed profiles
suggest an asteroid ma'am you need a
computer to see that I'd assume the
qualifications to be in this army would
at least be two spots ie on an eye chart
that asteroid might be heading towards
Earth though as Rico discovers talking
to his parents Jonny dad where's your
uniform bill I mean does a guy who
didn't want you to join the first place
I'm still a stickler for presentation no
what's that
Lorraine what's that giant foreshadowing
over us it turns out that list from the
asteroid which smashed Rico's hometown
million dead it's personally Rico's
parents but a new boomer one of my
favorite lass in the film probably comes
from this the war effort needs your
effort at work at home in your community
as of now cockroaches are officially
being called freedom bugs even our
heroes get a little time on the news
here's a bunch of my kids that look like
they could eat bugs for lunch
oh yeah get grant it that's already a
very awkward line but that delivery did
not make it any less awkward I got love
in my tummy tum tum some say the bugs
were provoked by the intrusion of humans
into their natural habitat that a live
and let live policy is preferable to war
with the bugs but then I remember the
same guy who directed this also directed
showgirls and that does put a crimp in
our plausible commentary Rico comes
across as old fling though as they seem
to cross paths
pitties I can't believe we're both
working for Planet spaceball but Karma's
new boyfriend seems to have some harsh
words Chuckie wait didn't forget a
lieutenant he's mobile infantry just
doesn't pay to be polite you got
something to say about the mobile
infantry he literally just did my
concern stairs not stopping this
don't mix it's like Steven Seagal and
acting just some things don't go
together they enter into heroes duty as
several their ships are shot it'd be
perfectly fine in a later scene like a
little nick on her head that's it how
are these goddamn medics they say the
bugs are literally shitting on them so
they try to attack they show us the
scene from the beginning as the media
continues to react to what's going on
it gets smart sensitive intelligence
have you ever met one I can't believe I
am hearing this hell invited the Mad
Hatter to this conversation rain bugs
frankly I find the idea of a bug vid
thinks offensive not as offensive for
Johnny Depp playing me but still
offensive still a better show than
hardball as our team recovers they're
given a new unit with a new lieutenant
tension on deck
[Music]
this better be Bruce Campbell oh it's
Michael Ironside close enough everyone
fights no one quits you don't do your
job I'll shoot you if you bring up the
next Karate Kid I'll also shoot you
after giving a bug bomb so big if you
put it orc and logo over it they go
inside and take care of any surviving
insects and for a gun that could have
given any generic explosion this one
makes one hell of a boom
mommy buy me that they take down one of
the other big bugs proving that their
blood is either pea-green super lobster
bisque I told you there'd be a soup
theme and they relaxed for the night as
Ironside brings out some entertainment
[Applause]
so violins are among the entertainment
given to the Troops
I am so fascinated by this world where
people who study the arts are ripped
commandos maybe my grinding is more
built than we think
so Nikko finally decides to give in to
Dizzy's advances
[Music]
this would be a lot more romantic
without the guy who just bought a
windowless van face again being a Busey
it's amazing this is the first time I'm
bringing this up hey if you thought the
spider-man kiss was romantic get a load
of this
okay I am literally smelling my pits
this is not as romantic as you think it
is
but Ironside tells them they're giving a
distress call report in ten minutes yes
sir
who's that with you sir make it twenty
minutes more people can die as long as
you're getting nookie one of the
soldiers gets caught by a flying bug
though and Ironside shoots in as opposed
to the monster I'd expect anyone in this
unit to do the same for me okay Rico sir
your acting sergeant movement out you
heard the lieutenant actually we did he
talked very softly why are we following
you they come across one of their bases
the bugs attacked when they say the line
any good movie of quality should have
the circus brands out any film that says
that is on the right path the bugs
attack though as our team is stuck in
their Alamo place sir we need pickup now
and it better be my girlfriend it'd be
dramatically convenient sure enough that
is who comes to rescue them but sadly at
the cost of their dear lieutenant
cherri me to the ship wait what are you
doing I only lost my legs I've lost
lives before nah I turned down five
episodes of Jett Jackson for this he's
not the only one who gets exterminated
though dizzy smiled for a second which
of course means you have to die
we're doing Mars Attacks to death you
can be alright this I got to have you
rain will make the flowers grow it looks
like they give her a funeral which must
have been tricky seeing how you have to
mourn the loss of a person named Izzi
without cracking a smile dizzy was my
friend she was a soldier I could have
done it then Dean you're a better actor
than I give you credit for more than
that she was a citizen of the Federation
of all the souls I've ever encountered
she rocked the most in the sack and if
there's anyone who doesn't still think
this is a satire of aggressive fascist
propaganda just look at how they dressed
doogie howser in this scene the books
lay a trap for us didn't they now
looking proof of intelligence isn't it
you knew and you sent them anyway you
don't approve well too bad we're in this
for the species boys and girls it's
simple numbers I could actually take him
more seriously it's Bart Simpson killing
someone in a TV movie this is kind of
adorable and every day I have to make
decisions that send hundreds of people
like you to their deaths didn't they
tell you colonel that's what the mobile
infantry is good for okay they told us
that that's why we sent you so they go
into attack again and somehow they don't
figure to spread out their ships rather
than keep them clustered together kind
of making you easier to hit isn't it oh
no I think they actually mean to kill us
off this time it's okay you'll just get
a scar right here it's fine how's this
for an embarrassing end death bite door
it's okay doors of how weighted the
smartest of sci-fi characters Carmen and
her boyfriend make it to the planet
where they're captured by the bugs and
taken to their white judge from the wall
Rita wants to save them but knows the
odds of them surviving are slim rescue
party cancel that you know as well as I
do she's already dead
aside from of love seen in wild things
her career is basically over so they go
to take out the bugs and Garmin's down
there word has it she's dead she's still
alive I thought you said she was dead
how many times can she die in this well
apparently at least one more time as
despite being stabbed through the chest
she picks up a gun and starts firing it
like nothing's happened to her what kind
of milk is she drinking cuz she's got
damn indestructible they pull out the
anus queen as gestapo Patrick Harris
reads its mind it's free it's afraid may
I be afraid to if I knew I was gonna see
you in 2 Smurfs movies so hyoe patrick
harris sums up who's really to thank for
today's victory this is when it turned
and it wasn't the mighty fleet it wasn't
some fancy new weapon was a drill
instructor names in
we captured a break who the hell is Zim
oh the drill instructor I guess he was
busy defeating the main bug while we
were focusing on our heroes kind of odd
mm go Zim we apparently could have done
it without you the film ends as had
begun with a recruitment video urging
people to join their battle and fight
the bugs soldiers like private a sleepy
and Lieutenant John Rico
well she practically is seems doable oh
[Music]
yes by the way the spacecraft still in
extreme danger may not make it back
attempting risky reentry blah blah blah
blah
and that was Starship Troopers isn't
really just another dumb action flick
don't get me wrong it's cliched
overblown and has a lot of generic
characters but I think that's the point
the whole film is shot like propaganda
making you imagine yourself as the
heroes Trey blood and immerse yourself
in the battle when someone dies it's
because of those damn bugs and any
criticism to understand why this war is
even happening is pushed off to the side
for la war cries if you look at this as
a film that would be shown in their
universe which again isn't difficult
given the PSAs they show it can display
it interesting mirrors showing what we
can look like when we get more focused
on destroying our enemies rather than
finding other ways to peacefully solve
the problem and that's just one way to
look at there's many other ways you can
read into this if you choose to go
looking for it maybe you don't want to
maybe you just want to see a
shoot-'em-up bug movie and as those go
this isn't that bad at that either but I
truly believe there's more to this silly
looking film than meets the eye oh I see
you still don't believe me
no you don't have pants on again no just
kidding this time we don't believe you
you know what fine because in the future
people will see this for the masterpiece
that it is it is the future this film is
over 20 years old well people are
starting to realize it's brilliant never
anyone talking about it well they will
they will if I've raised enough
awareness you never will I have the
determination you're unbelievably lazy
boy just laugh all you want your penis
actually a censor bar it's a very
specific birth defect
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
yum-yum-yum
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing
child fun International founded in 1938
child fun International is a global
child development and protection agency
to help children and families around the
world they help children break the
generational cycle of poverty and
achieve their full potential no matter
what their situation is this
organization works in 27 countries
assisting approximately 19 million
children and family members and are a
member of the child fund Alliance a
global network of 12 children
development organizations if you look at
their site in their YouTube channel you
can see all the various ways various
people and various rewards of helping
those who wish to give a strong
promising future these people work so
hard through so many challenges to give
hope to people that have almost lost all
of it but with good people like this and
your donation hope can always find a way
click on the link and see what you can
do to help those who give so much for
the future
[Music]
you